Seaside duels.
Heartbroken mothers.
Vengeful thugs.
As 1923's first season comes to a close the
growing Dutton family sits more precariously
than ever.
If fans of Taylor Sheridan's work haven't
noticed by now, one of the prevailing themes
is the importance of family.
From his early features like Hell or High
Water to Sylvester Stallone's crime comedy
Tulsa King, Sheridan's stories have almost
all revolved around the power and pull of family.
Nowhere is this truer than in Yellowstone
and its spin-off 1923.
This theme runs most obviously through the
story of Jacob Dutton and his clan, and how
there is nothing more that motivates the staunch
patriarch than his love of his kin.
He does everything for them and them alone.
The finale makes clear that families come
in all manner of shapes and sizes, and it
doesn't matter what shape it may be — family
is all that matters.
Tragically, injustice abounds in 1923 as much
as it does in the real world when the law
comes to arrest rancher Zane Davis' wife for
the crime of marrying a white man.
At the same time, Jacob's family is falling
apart, with his new niece miscarrying a pregnancy,
and the family home on the verge of being
taken by Donald Whitfield.
"The word decent doesn't apply to me."
While freedom to live, work and love are generally
held as fundamental human rights, 1923 takes
a hard look at the many ways these needs are
denied to large populations of people.
By the end of Season 1, many of the characters
can see that freedom is not always guaranteed.
On the reservation, Teonna's fight for freedom
forces her to kill, pushing back against the
oppression she faces after being taken from
her family and forced into a Catholic boarding school.
In their attempt to take away her identity
through cruelty and torture, they inadvertently
unleash her inner warrior.
Now, if she wants to live free, she must fight
harder than ever before.
Luckily, she stands alongside her rescuers,
her father, and Pete Plenty Clouds, as they
look to start a new life together while on
the run from America's lawmen.
The Duttons, meanwhile, face their own fight
for freedom.
As a new day in America dawns and more and
more laws begin to strip them of their sovereignty,
Jacob Dutton is forced to fight fire with
fire.
That may mean a fight in the fields with guns
and guts, or it might mean a battle in the
boardroom, facing off against ruthless businessmen
who would use guile and cunning to take from
him everything that he's built.
Not long after the events of 1883, the Wild
West is already fading as pioneers begin building
up the West and the law starts to make its
way to the frontier.
By the era of 1923, however, the mountains
of Montana are firmly becoming part of the
modern world.
Though they are still well behind the big
cities like New York and San Francisco, we've
seen through the course of the season that
automobiles are slowly taking over for horses,
and electricity is finally finding its way
into homes.
Jacob Dutton has been resistant to such change,
though his wife Cara seems happy to have a
washing machine to make her household chores
easier.
In the finale, we see the truest extent of
modern changes, as horse hitches in the city
have been removed from the street to make
way for automobile parking spaces, and new
20th century laws allow bankers and tycoons
to take away a person's house and home through
shady business deals.
Jacob Dutton, a man born before the Civil
War, is a remnant of an old world where problems
were solved with a fist or a gun, and, somewhat
paradoxically, neighbors respected each other's
livelihoods and cared for their community.
Likewise, Teonna's people, who once roamed
free and loved the land, now have modern American
laws dictating their way of life.
Change is inevitable, and if 1923 tells us
anything, it's that while change can be good,
it can also cause harm when controlled by
the wrong people.
"I have compassion, but I have no mercy."
While on the run from the law throughout the
later portion of Season 1, Teonna has been
forced to kill several of her pursuers before
she gets discovered by her father.
With a U.S. Marshal on their tail, they're
forced to flee to Wyoming where they hope
to join a new clan of Comanche down south
and begin a new chapter of their lives.
However, with so much turmoil in her young
life, Teonna defies her father and begins
a romance with Pete Plenty Clouds, partially
due to the fact that her experiences this
season have taught her that tomorrow isn't
guaranteed.
These lessons have also been learned by the
Duttons, who are ready to take matters into
their own hands, rather than to wait out the
return of their intended savior, Spencer.
With Donald Whitfield at their door ready
to take the land beneath their feet and steal
the Yellowstone Ranch, and Banner Creighton
ready to see them all dead in a hail of gunfire,
waiting is not an option.
For all of our protagonists, prosperity and
survival depend on taking action immediately,
because there may not be a later.
This is a wisdom that Spencer and Alexandra
learn earlier this season.
Like Teonna and Pete, they jump headfirst
into a romance because the dangers of life
allow no room for patience.
They were right not to waste the time, as
they've been forced apart by fate by the end
of the season.
In the season finale, Spencer and Alexandra
finally set sail for American shores, but
they are forced to deal with a new problem.
This time, though, it's not the harsh sting
of nature that interferes with their love,
but the spite of a spurned lover — Alex's
former husband-in-waiting Arthur.
In the finale, it's revealed that Arthur is
more than just Alex's ex-fiancé, but the
Earl of Sussex, whose father is a prince in
the line of succession.
With all three forced together during their
voyage on the RMS Majestic ocean liner, Alex
is initially determined to avoid a confrontation
by staying in her cabin for the entirety of
their trip.
But when frustrations with their situation
boil over, Alex and Spencer agree that the
only way to deal with their problems is head
on.
Unfortunately, this leads to a new crisis,
as Arthur challenges Spencer to a duel on
the deck.
Spencer wins the day but is forced to throw
Arthur overboard when the bitter ex-lover
pulls a pistol, leading to the hunter's arrest
and expulsion from the ship and a possibly
permanent separation from the woman he loves.
More than any series yet, 1923 appears to
be Taylor Sheridan's way of making crystal
clear how he feels about the rich and powerful.
More than once he's shown the villainous mining
magnate Donald Whitfield using his wealth
to attain control over others in perverse
and corrupt ways.
In a revealing moment, Whitfield spells out
what might be the series' biggest message.
Chatting with his crony Banner Creighton,
Whitfield says bluntly that true wealth isn't
just being rich, it’s being so rich that
you can't possibly spend all of your money
in your own lifetime.
"I could never spend all the money I've made.
What I do now ensures that my great grandchildren
can't either.
To achieve this generational wealth, Whitfield
proclaims that he must take from those he
deems unworthy, and his target is the Dutton
ranch.
In one of the episode's final scenes, he even
admits that he feels no need to act with honor
or respect.
Loud and clear, 1923 tells us that the search
for power and money leads to evil, and that
wealth alone is not a signal of virtue, nobility,
or strength of character.
By the conclusion of the first season of 1923,
Jacob Dutton has found himself in a world
of trouble.
He's been surrounded by his enemies: the rich
and powerful Donald Whitfield and the thuggish
and vengeful Banner Creighton.
While Jacob wants justice for the family members
who Banner directly and indirectly murdered,
the law is making it more and more difficult
to get it.
However, Jacob is far from blameless, as the
feud begins when he hangs Banner's men for
trespassing on his land so his sheep could
graze.
Jacob knows that the law isn't always about
justice, and as a man of the Old West, he
takes it into his own hands.
This decision comes back to bite him, as the
case against Banner falls apart due to Dutton's
hasty attempt at frontier justice.
The law also isn't helping Teonna on the reservation,
as it's unwilling to consider the abuse and
torture she receives at the hands of the sisters
at the Catholic boarding school.
Likewise, Spencer's story is also marred by
the corruption of law enforcement.
Aboard the Majestic, Arthur's royal father
uses his position to shift the law in his
favor by having Spencer removed from the ocean
liner and ripped from Alex's arms after Spencer
defeats his son.
"This ship sails under a British flag, and
a prince in succession has order you removed
from the vessel."
While many believe that the future is what
they make it to be, many others believe destiny
to be preordained, even if we feel like we
can exercise free will in the moment.
"Nothing Left to Lose" solidifies that 1923
clearly stands in the latter camp, with its
characters under the impression destiny is
not something they have much of a say in.
For Jack and Elizabeth, destiny has dire consequences.
We learn that the attack on the ranch earlier
in the season may have permanently impaired
Elizabeth's ability to bear children.
Following her miscarriage, she ponders what
kind of life she will have if she is unable
to start a family.
In response, Jack declares that if it's not
their destiny to be parents, then they shall
find out together what their destiny really
is.
He doesn't feel that he chose Elizabeth for
his wife, but that destiny made the match
and he went along for the ride.
He also wonders if perhaps their destiny is
to raise someone else's children — orphans
who need a home — just as his Aunt Cara
did when she and Jacob arrived in Montana
after the death of James and Margaret Dutton
left their children alone.
As Yellowstone has demonstrated for years,
a central theme in the Dutton shared universe
is that of a found family.
In the parent series, we've seen this play
out more than once, with son Jamie discovered
to have been adopted by John Dutton as a baby.
Later, he brought a wayward Rip Wheeler into
the fold, if not as family, then as the next
best thing.
Dutton's daughter Beth, along with her husband
Rip, later fostered young Carter, an orphan
without a home, proving that family is built
off of far more than blood.
In 1923 we learn that it was Jacob and Cara
who raised James and Margaret's children as
their own after their deaths.
What's more, in the finale, we get our first
hints that this custom of caring for the unwanted
and orphaned may be something of a family
custom that took roots decades before the
events of Yellowstone.
Following Elizabeth's miscarriage, Jack Dutton
suggests that rather than have their own children,
their future may see them adopting children
who need a home as a way of expanding their
family and continuing the Dutton legacy.
Could this mean that Kevin Costner's John
Dutton is the child of an adopted Dutton himself?
This would certainly establish a thematic
link between the two series and explain John's
penchant for caring for lost souls.
For now, however, that's a question best left
for another time.
As the Beatles so fondly reminded listeners
in their hit "All You Need Is Love," love
is a powerful and unpredictable force.
Throughout Season 1 of 1923, every hero has
to put their faith in this joyous feeling.
Jacob has mentioned repeatedly how his love
for his wife Cara has kept him strong, while
Jack's love for his wife Elizabeth has seen
him through the death of his father.
Even Teonna is finding solace in her newfound
love as she escapes a life of torment and anguish.
However, the lesson may have been learned
best by Spencer Dutton, the prodigal son of
the Yellowstone ranch who begins the series
estranged from the family and seeking his
fortune a world away.
Spencer never felt like he ever needed anybody
but himself, but when an adventure-seeking
maiden named Alexandra hitches her ride to
his, he discovers the power of love and all
it could help him accomplish.
But he also has to deal with the dark side,
and the pain love can cause when it is taken
away from you.
Separated from Alex at the close of the finale,
Spencer's desperate cries to his new wife
prove that no matter what anyone takes from
you, love binds forever.